pumping out with the last drops to save
Iraq's crucial Rivers
the smaller amount of water from the
reservoir in ambal province is going
into the Euphrates
the river's level has been declining
drastically largely because of dams in
neighboring turkey
Iraq has also experienced years of
drought and unprecedented water
shortages
we started the project with 15 electric
pumps and 33 diesel operated pumps their
current operating at around 75 cubic
meters per second hoping to feed Central
and Southern regions
but experts worry this water with high
levels of salt could pose a threat to
humans and the environment
the salt used to be washed away by a
natural occurrence when the reservoir
was full but that may not be the case
now with the reservoir at its lowest
levels the Euphrates River needs at
least 300 cubic meter a second to revive
in remote areas
the full capacity of tartar is 85
billion cubic meters only the upper 45
billions are fit for consumption but the
lower 40 billions are salinated by the
nature of terrain and contaminated in
fact it is dangerous not only for humans
but also for animals and plants as well
Lakes are thought is the biggest
artificial Lake in Iraq it has been
draining directly to the Euphrates since
it was created in
1956. despite International concern
local water authorities have not
prepared for dry seasons this is how
much the Euphrates has lost in recent
years the top of this Reservoir used to
reach up to this Hyatt and the river
used to have between 30 and 40 billion
cubic meters of water now its levels
have significantly declined to only
about 6 billion cubic meters and with
temperatures exceeding 50 degrees
Celsius in some regions
large areas of once lavish lands have
turned it arid
as water levels dwindle to a Trinkle in
Iraq's Central and Southern regions many
areas have become a wasteland including
the UNESCO world heritage marshlands
the reservoir managers are hopeful the
common grainy season will fill up the
reserves and replace what they lost but
for the years to come the lack of water
here in the cradle of civilization could
mean the end of communities that have
lived by the rivers for thousands of
years
foreign